tomorrow
um just hearing that he has died taken
back into hospital last Friday he had
suffered from ill health sometimes he
had done and of course one of Europe's
most recognizable political leaders
colorful controversial he was prime
minister of Italy at three different
times first in the mid 90s and then up
between 2008 and 2000 and 11 and of
course endless controversy surrounding
him he was then convicted of of tax
fraud but has not been in obscurity
recently he actually returned to the
Italian Senate just last year it's been
very outspoken in his comments about the
war in Ukraine has been described as a
as a Putin apologist by some and there
will be much to pick over in Italy about
his legacy some say paved the way for
other populist leaders across Europe and
indeed across the pond in the U.S and um
you know he met all the key figures
there is with Barack Obama of course he
met Tony Blair many times when he was
prime minister and
um you know I think for all the
controversy that surrounded him he
remained very much at the center of
Italian politics right up until the last
few months when we know that he has
suffered from serious ill health I mean
it's what 10 11 years ago now when uh he
was on trial in Milan facing allegations
that he paid for sex with a minor and
abused his power as well he stepped back
or was forced to step back from Italian
politics after that well I would have
finished off many a political career but
he continued to make
um you know outspoken comments about
many
um issues in Italian politics he's been
commenting openly about the
um you know the current prime minister
uh Georgia Maloney and since he's been
back in the Senate even in the last few
months um he's been he's been commenting
a lot on um the sort of controversy in
Italy about
um you know whether to support the war
in Ukraine militarily so he's been very
much at the center of things and you
know it's really he's really one of the
the most recognizable European leaders
of the last couple of decades and um I'm
sure there will be many paying tribute
to him with very mixed emotions uh given
that
um you know he was always someone who
said it as he thought and uh and uh you
know they may there may even be uh
comparisons to another uh former prime
minister here who uh you know
um always always said it as as he
thought it was and and uh and
um perhaps with bigger consequences than
I think it was worth something like 13
billion dollars at his height made his
money initially in property but then
went on to be shall call him a media
Mogul media Mogul owned football clubs
as well I believe he made he made
enormous amount of of money and was
through his media Empire as well
extremely influential uh in in Italian
politics and
um you know continue continued that
right up until
um really the last few months we we know
he'd had open heart surgery in 2016 but
seemed to be very much uh back in the
middle of things after that there he is
with the with the current prime minister
and it's only in the last few days that
we learned that he was back in hospital
yeah apparently he started his career
singing on cruise ships is what I'm
hearing but he then entered the business
world uh in construction back in the
1960s certainly as you said a headline
figure as well as European politics was
concerned he went back into hospital I
think around saying last Friday we were
told that it was just for a checkup but
he had been um poorly with the open
heart surgery previously also had
contracted covid I think three years ago
and was incredibly poorly during that
time that's right yes contracted covid
which of course
um was was
um you know raging in Italy before it
came to the UK and
um you know look at has had some severe
health problems over the last few years
but still seemed to be back in the
center of things even as soon as even as
recently as the last few months and
um was you know on on Italian TV was was
seeing it still as a kind of King maker
in Italian politics
um he sort of Hit the headlines in the
UK I'm sure you remember when uh Tony
and Cherie Blair Went to went to stay
with him yeah yeah and the controversy
about that and you know when um okay
back to you in a second tomorrow media
Tycoon who led three Italian Governors
between 1994 and
2011 has died at the age of 86. um
Siobhan's on the phone for us uh Siobhan
what more do we know good morning
good morning Kay so the news is true in
the last 10 minutes or so we knew that
Silvio Berlusconi had been readmitted to
hospital in Milan on Friday
um he's been treated
um the long term basically for leukemia
and he was going into Hospital on Friday
for some checkup tests the doctors
didn't feel happy with the results that
came back and decided to readmit him
there wasn't a lot of news over the
weekend but this morning we got word
from a source at the hospital that his
situation and his health had
deteriorated and it's now been confirmed
uh by a source to us as well as in local
media in Italy that Silvio Berlusconi
has died at the age of 86 after battling
leukemia now as you were saying he of
course is an extremely colorful sticker
in Italian uh politics
he started his rise to his billionaire
status by getting involved for example
in TV he was a TV Mogul but also
involved in other businesses as well at
one point involved in AC Milan for
example involved in shopping centers as
well and of course a huge figure uh in
politics in Italy as well managing to
bounce back from several scandals of
course including the Bunga Bunga sex
scandals which held the headlines for
weeks and weeks and despite his age and
those scandals he'd LED Italy three
times as prime minister and was back in
politics again as a senator recently for
the fossa Italia party but his health
has been deteriorating we saw before
Christmas a big scare over his health
he'd just spent six weeks in hospital
had recently come out of hospital and
then was readmitted as I said on Friday
and today the news confirms that he has
died
okay Bernard Siobhan thank you nicknamed
IL cavaliera the night
um often uh considered
um the king maker uh I think I'm right
in saying tomorrow in Italian politics
that's right and as to his personal life
he'd been married twice and actually had
a what's called a symbolic marriage
they're not a legally binding one to a
woman who is age 32 just last March
um so uh his five adult children
reportedly not not too happy about that
and what might happen to his five
billion pound Fortune so um yes leading
a colorful life right up until the end
yeah indeed so if you're just tuning uh
where you come to us with the news that
the former Italian Prime Minister Silvio
Berlusconi has died at the age of 86 the
media Tycoon who led three Italian
governments just hearing that from
Siobhan there as you can see managed to
attract political figures not only to
Europe but also traveling to the United
States as well the Oval Office there
with President Obama as I said LED three
Italian governments between 1994 and
2011 his Forza Italian party a junior
partner in the current ruling Coalition
he'd been suffering from leukemia for
some time he did contract covid in
December of 2020 and had struggled with
the after effects of that he said that
it had been the worst illness of his
life so the breaking news is our that
the former Italian Prime Minister Sylvia
burlesconi has died at the age of 86.
[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
breaking news the former Italian Prime
Minister Silvio Berlusconi has died at
the age of 86.
also this American companies say they're
losing confidence in investing in the UK
where she soon that course for Britain
to become a global leader in business
technology investment as London Tech
week gets underway
a Rebrand for the former UK arm of
Silicon Valley Bank as HSBC unveils its
new tech banking plans
plus new research suggests students want
a wider range of Technology subjects at
school including Esports
[Music]
thank you
good morning this is incoming live in
our business and economic news from the
Heart of the City where we start this
out with some breaking news the former
Italian Prime Minister Silvio bernasconi
has died the 86 year old media Tycoon
had been treated in hospital for a lung
infection linked to Chronic leukemia he
led the country three times from 1994 to
95 2001 to 2006 and 2008 to 2011 during
his last term in office Italy came close
to a Greek style debt crisis and he
faced numerous scandals most notably
around his notorious bunga bunga parties
our Europe correspondent Adam Parsons
has been taking a look back at his life
and career
he was impossible to ignore Silvio
Berlusconi was a giant figure in Italian
life for decades on end in politics
business Sport and on the global stage
his fortune was built on broadcasting he
constructed a media Empire and made a
vast Fortune
he spent some of that on molding AC
Milan into Europe's best football team
and then turned his attention to
politics from the center right he led
four separate governments spending more
time as prime minister than any other
post-war Italian politician we find
but it was never straightforward
Berlusconi was cited in dozens of
criminal investigations mostly around
claims of fraud he said that was
persecution and claimed to have been in
court two and a half thousand times
trouble did follow him remember this
woman a Moroccan dancer nicknamed Ruby
heart stealer
Berlusconi was convicted of paying her
for sex when she was just 17 years old
at one of his lavish bunga bunga parties
they were taking part in a burlesque
competition
and they trained for it because these
women by their very nature are
exhibitionists they are show girls who
like to put on a show and compete
but he won an appeal and laughed off the
Scandal bunga bunga became a catchphrase
not a source of Shame
then came a conviction for tax fraud
that he couldn't beat Berlusconi was at
his lowest air and protested furiously
on one of his own TV stations
in exchange for the commitments I have
made over almost 20 years in favor of my
country and coming almost at the end of
my public life I received as a reward
accusations and a verdict that is
founded on absolutely nothing it takes
away my personal freedom and my
political rights
he was a global figure he hosted three
G8 meetings that is a record
but his brand of diplomacy was eccentric
he famously left Angela Merkel hanging
around while he took a phone call
eventually she walked off
to Italy only to cheerfully stroll away
from their joint scheduled press
conference leaving Jose zapatero utterly
bemused
but bellisconi was blessed with an
infectious smile Rolling Stone magazine
once named him their rock star of the
year he had Charisma and he knew how to
get in touch with people and even if
sometimes he could
[Music]
look like a little bit strange eccentric
but at the end he was a very friendly
parent
[Applause]
remarkably he returned to politics once
more part of the Coalition that pushed
Giorgio Maloney into power still a
political heavyweight into his late 80s
Silvio Berlusconi was a man who lived
for the spotlight
I'll join him on the line as our Europe
correspondent Shavon Robinson before he
became a politician he was of course one
of Italy's most successful ever business
people a lot of questions about what
happens to his business Empire but I
guess also what happens to Italy's
ruling Coalition of which he was a part
yes so as you say and as Adam was just
reporting there he was a Media Mobile a
billionaire and in the 1970s he created
his first cable TV company and by the
80s uh he was basically ruling the
airwave here in Italy uh he went on to
invest in a range of other businesses so
having involvement in AC Milan football
club for example in shopping centers
then but then of course this huge figure
on the Italian political scene as well
nicknamed the kingmaker role and he had
three different stints uh leading the
country here one of those made him the
longest serving uh prime minister that
Italy has seen and that's despite the
fact that he was uh linked to so many
scandals of course the infamous bunga
bunga scandals but also a tax fraud
conviction allegations of course as well
and despite the fact that he was 86 he
was still playing a huge part not in
politics he's also Italia party was part
of the ruling Coalition he also was the
senator himself but we have seen his
health deteriorating uh in the last
decade he had open heart surgery and
then since the end of last year there
has really been a marked periodation in
his house he'd been in hospital for
around six weeks being treated for
complications with leukemia he'd come
out and then on Friday gone back for
what we're told
to see how he was doctors weren't happy
then with the results of the test
decided to keep him in and then today
sources told us that his house really
had deteriorated that his family had
gone to his bedside and it's now been
confirmed uh both by Source within the
hospital but also from local media here
that Silvio Berlusconi has died at the
age of 86.
thanks Yvonne